let's get more now on the situation this
ryan airplane that was flying from
athens to lithuania
it was diverted to minsk let's speak to
our moscow correspondent diana magnay
who's on the phone now
diana what do we know about why this
plane was diverted
well because it was carrying a prominent
opposition blogger activist who for a
long time now has been based
in vilnius lithuania because it's
dangerous for him
uh to be in minsk or in
uh belarus and obviously um
the president himself alexander
lukashenko found out that he was on
board this plane
from athens to vilnius and ordered his
kgb
his security services to have that plane
stopped
so we know that um a mig fighter jet
accompanied this minor plane
uh when it passed into belarus airspace
and the kgb agents who were clearly on
board
must have told the ryanair pilot that
there were explosives on board
and got him to land where upon this
blogger was arrested
so it's pretty amazing um you know that
that lukashenko has managed to stop a
plane
essentially in mid-air and make it land
in belarus
reuters are reporting that the belarus
news agency state news agency
are saying that lukashenko himself
personally ordered
the warplane to escort that ryanair
boeing to minsk
um just tell us a bit more about who
this man is roman protest
protacivic excuse me and why would
koshenko want to detain him so badly
so he is the co-founder of nexter which
is
a opposition channel um
it has released over the last
since last august all the videos that
are
uh that show the opposition which is the
majority of the country
out on the street and it has
basically been a very prominent voice
showing
what alexander lukashenko does in his
country
which is why and has been and how he's
been trying to suppress the opposition
or essentially the entire bella russian
nation
into submission after rigged elections
last year
and he has been coming after journalists
one after the other
and uh has labelled nectar an extremist
organization
and is trying to scare anyone
in belarus who is uh acting you know
in a journalistic capacity and clearly
try and scare
anyone outside of belarus too
and it's it's an extraordinary thing to
have done and i wonder how
the international community can react
seeing as
really alexander lukashenko has no
authority over
um the likes of ryanair um
clearly threatened the ryanair pilot
clearly managed to get
his own security agents on board um
and and had this plane diverted
and landed at minsk we have about i
don't know 25
bella russian journalists who are
currently in jail on
a selection of spurious
charges we have the likes of nexer
labelled extremist this man rahman
is the co-founder would face up to 15
years
in jail if there is no way of getting
him out and at the moment
it looks very unlikely given how little
external influence
anybody has on what happens in belarus
and in belarus
villa russian jails but it is
extraordinary that
president shenko can have done what he
clearly has just done
intervened in on an international flight
a ryanair flight that has nothing to do
with
with belarus um to detain a blogger
who he is clearly scared of it just goes
to show the length
to which alexander lukachenko will go to
try and suppress
the bella russian opposition it's
interesting because um
talking of the opposition um the belarus
opposition leader svetlana
sikhanovskaya she's called for an ayatta
investigation
into this diverted flight and she's also
called for sanctions
up to removal from the international
civil aviation organization that's the
un
aviation body iko the lithuanian
president
has also demanded obviously the release
but he's also called on nato and eu
allies to immediately react to
quote the threat posed to international
civil aviation by the belarus regime
the international community must take
immediate steps that this
does not repeat this is in reuters
reporting
um the lithuanian president um sent this
out in an email statement
he also said that he promised to discuss
this on monday tomorrow at an eu summit
and one wonders how much how much
leverage
does the international community have
over lukashenko diana
well that is the question i mean to date
the uh
rigged elections and they were rigged
that saw him re-elected as president
last
august um and his very violent
uh repression of all the
subsequent protests
um sanctions have been levied on on
his staff they have been levied on his
police force they have been
levied on individuals within his
security apparatus
i don't think i think i'm right in
saying that they haven't been levied
against him personally although i'm not
sure that that would really make
much difference to the situation but uh
none of those sanctions to date have
made any difference whatsoever
in changing his behavior now i wonder if
this means perhaps that um bellavia the
bella russian
airliner will face repercussions if
you know belarus's activities on an
international
level may see some kind of curtailment
but i mean
the international community till now
through sanctions has really not managed
to
make very much difference to what
belarus does within belarus
it's not called europe's last
dictatorship
um you know for no reason so i think
that
uh western heads will have to think very
long and hard
about what they can do in this situation
to make a difference and i do wonder
what
difference that can make to the fate of
roman pritchovich who has
for his own safety lived outside of
belarus
i think we've lost diana but um as diana
was saying there
um the latest is that that ryanair plane
was flying from athens
to lithuania it's still in minsk and
roman tassovich has been detained and
remains
so